cancelled flights empty Plains and
eerily quiet airports this is what the
impact of the corona virus epidemic
looks like through the lens of travelers
and the effect is visible in the skies
too one year ago this is how many planes
were flying above China and now that
same airspace looks like this the
epidemic has led to an 80 percent drop
in traffic at China's busiest airports
the reduction in global capacity
measured by how many seats remain
grounded is greater than it was
following SARS and even greater than
after 9/11 I think we have a whole
different ballgame now compared to the
2001 2003 issues so what impact is this
having on the aviation industry if we
look back in ten years time with this
we've seen as a blip or a game-changer
the financial implications of suspended
flights and routes are huge China has
become the second biggest aviation
market globally with Airlines like
American Airlines are flying as many as
twenty eight flights weekly obviously
now with the corona virus outbreak
that's dropped down to zero to make
matters worse many cancellations and
suspensions came around Chinese New Year
when airlines normally see a boost in
ticket sales beyond impacting just
Chinese air traffic and you're looking
at where do those passengers connect
beyond China where do they go when
they're departing China a narrow-body
aircraft is is costing in the order of
$10,000 a day whether that's being
financed or or whether it's being leased
if you're not flying it it's not just
the $10,000 per day per aircraft
you've got crews sitting around flight
crews cabin crews yet the aircraft
itself will still need maintenance a new
wide-body aircraft is going to be
costing as much as $50,000 a day Cathay
Pacific and Asiana Airlines have both
asked thousands of staff to take unpaid
leave Hong Kong Airlines announced it
would lay off four
workers its chairman said the changes
were about ensuring its very survival as
reported by local media globally IATA is
forecasting in twenty nine point three
billion dollar loss in revenue for 2020
for context the Icelandic volcano
eruption the disrupted air traffic
across Europe for several days cost the
industry 1.7 billion dollars in lost
revenue though nobody knows how long the
epidemic will last the industry is
already bracing for a hit that he's
expected to be harder than after 911 or
SARS SARS is kind of the benchmark here
the global share of the Chinese economy
was so much lower than it is now and now
where were China's 19% the global
economy it's a much bigger impact with
the South outbreak in 2003 we saw took a
number of months for the airlines to
recover both demand and profits what
we're really waiting to see now is how
long the impact of the corona virus will
be and that really depends on when we
hit peak for which we really have no
estimate at the moment back in 9/11 in
2001 it took about nine months before we
saw really the industry recover from the
impact of the events now with the corona
virus it's a very different situation
and it's difficult to give an assessment
and analysts are expecting that with the
corona virus this could actually last
quite a bit longer
after years of fast growth the epidemic
could cause the global airline industry
to contract for the first time since the
financial crisis according to industry
analysts Airlines say they're looking
into ways to limit the damage with
Chinese companies hoping they will get
support from the government like they
did after SARS with bailouts tax breaks
and mergers in terms of the types of
airlines that could be affected by this
it could really be across the whole
spectrum it won't just be small airlines
or large airlines or Airlines with a
specific type this will be impacting you
know actually every airline that
operates in and out of China